Finding signs of life on other planets...
...beyond the Earth would be a way of answering the biggest...
...questions that we've had as a species so far.
Where do we come from, are we alone?
Of course these questions are not the exclusive purview of scientists.
People have been asking them for as long as there is any...
...record of them being able to ask these questions.
What is special about this moment and our role in it...
...as scientists, is that for the first time we're actually...
...able because we have the tools to answer these questions.
So a group of scientists, led by Jane Greaves...
...from the University of Cardiff, were looking for signs,...
...for chemical signs on Venus, that shouldn't belong there.
And one of such molecules is phosphine.
And they, unexpectedly, they actually were able to find a signal...
...that belongs to this molecule.
So then, we raced, for us to figure out what could be the reason for phosphine on Venus.
And this is where our MIT team comes.
When we actually looked at all kinds of processes, chemical and physical,...
...that could potentially produce phosphine in Venusian environments.
This is an atmosphere.
The surface of the planet is completely, completely uninhabited.
The atmosphere is the only place in which life actually could, in principle, exist.
There is a belt of clouds.
And we concluded that there is no known chemical and physical...
...process that could conceivably produce phosphine.
So this adds to the mystery of Venus.
And then, this opens, a very, rather bold possibility...
...that there might be something living in the clouds of Venus.